by now you've seen the Rihanna Super
Bowl halftime show unless you've been
living under a rock you guys I was
already a Rihanna stand but my respect
went through the roof when I learned how
crazy this show was behind the scenes
first of all we know Rihanna is a
professional and can sell out pretty
much any venue in the world but did you
know that she was the first woman to
perform at the Super Bowl while pregnant
I'll just spoil it for all you rock
dwellers yep Rihanna's pregnant it's a
long nine or ten months girl you know in
fact the belly rub she did during her
performance of diamonds was totally
candid according to Adam Blackstone her
co-director of the Super Bowl show I'll
tell you more about Adam Blackstone in a
second but first let's talk fashion that
gorgeous red costume Rihanna wore for
the show was custom made by legendary
designer Jonathan Anderson the creative
director of low according to an
interview with CNN the costume was
inspired by flightgear which was pretty
fitting for the performance where
Rihanna was literally performing 60 feet
above the field but don't worry those
platforms were seriously strong
apparently strong enough to carry a
freight train Adam Blackstone and his
team really embraced the stage making
the Super Bowl halftime show the
performance of a lifetime many fans have
anxiously speculated that this show
might mean Rihanna's about to drop an
album yes you're still gonna get music
from me but I wouldn't hold my breath it
seems like Riri is pretty content with
motherhood at the moment she told
British Vogue in an interview you really
don't remember life before that's the
craziest thing ever you literally try
and remember it even if she didn't play
any new music the crowd and the internet
still went wild this Super Bowl
performance was chock full of hits if
anything this show was a testament to
her star power proving Rihanna can rock
any house anywhere anytime in a recent
interview with Men's Health Magazine
Adam Blackstone admitted there were 46
different versions of the setlist for
the show why so many different setlists
well when you have 113 million people
watching a 10 minute performance you
have to be pretty intentional with the
time it was more about how she wanted to
navigate through the songs did we want
to do it by Tempo did we want to do it
by content did we want to do it by
storyline Adam said in the interview in
fact there were so many last minute
changes the setlist was finalized at
three o'clock on performance day talk
about crunch time though to be fair most
halftime show performances operate on a
crazy fast timeline Rihanna Adam and
Lead choreographer Paris gobel only
started rehearsing in mid-December
meaning they had about two months to put
together the performance of a lifetime
I'll tell you all about the rehearsal
process in a sec but I just remembered I
have to tell you who Adam Blackstone is
Adam Blackstone is pretty much a Super
Bowl genius I learned from the best he's
been involved in a bunch of Super Bowl
performances
including Justin Timberlake in 2018 and
Dr Dre in 2022. also I thought this was
so awesome Adam has been a crazy
talented multi-instrumentalist since the
age of 18. this guy is a straight up
Legend okay now back to the rehearsal
process guys keep in mind while Rihanna
was rehearsing for the Super Bowl she
also put on a Savage X Fenty show and
attended the Golden Globes now get this
she even went back to the Super Bowl
rehearsal after the Golden Globe
ceremony that's how dedicated she was
but she didn't act alone those Flawless
backup dancers had a crazy rehearsal
schedule too we had to move from a
rehearsal Studio to a bigger Studio
where we could fit the set into an
actual Stadium Arena so we could do what
we needed to do so we could stimulate
what was going to happen at the State
Farm Stadium Adam told mens Health he
also said people were typically
rehearsing for eight hours a day every
Hip Flex backbend snap had to be
precisely choreographed Adam and Paris
Global demanded everyone work full out
at every rehearsal which meant according
to them giving it your 10 000 maximum
percent a lot of people were asking
where's Drake where's Jay-Z people start
calling me
guys seriously did Rihanna look like she
needed any help up there the fact that
she performed alone was an intentional
statement this was her moment to shine
when Nate Burleson of CBS Sports asked
if there were going to be any guest
appearances at the Super Bowl show
Rihanna gave the best response ever
saying thinking about bringing someone a
word I'm not sure obviously she was
talking about her baby she's so
incredible so what did you guys think of
this Super Bowl performance is it just
me or did those floating platforms kind
of remind you of a level in Super Mario
Brothers let us know in the comments
below and be sure to subscribe to the
channel to stay up to date on all the
things